This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross one of the best T.V. shows that premiered this
year according to our T.V. critic David Bianculli was master of none a comedy
series on Netflix co-created by Izzy's Ansari and Alan yang.
They also wrote many of the episodes. They first worked together on Parks and
Recreation where Ansari was one of the stars and yang one of the writers.
We're going to hear the interview I recorded with them in November as we continue our series of
some of our favorite interviews of the year.
Ansari stars and master of none as an actor trying to make it in movies and
T.V. But in addition to all the obstacles typically faced by actors his
options are further limited by being Indian
American Many of the stories in the series revolve around issues Ansari and
yang have faced regarding the entertainment world relationships and being first
generation Americans.
And series parents are from India Yanks parents are from Taiwan. Let's start
with a scene from an episode called Indians on
T.V. and Sarah's character dev is in a restaurant talking with his friend
Ravi who's also an Indian American actor trying to find good
roles Devis complaining that some of the Indian characters on T.V. and in
movies have actually been played by white people including a character in the one nine hundred
eighty S. film short circuit to. Ravi who is played by Ravi Patel speaks first.
Well sometimes I can
tell they are white got a plane in England.
With the rope Rover. With Johnny
Fontane but you don't know the point which do you know you're talking about
do that I feel like a robot of the Indian they need.
In the White House that Fisher Stevens make up
what Yeah they got a real robot a fake Union.
I'm sorry man I'm just. Well missions in a lot of emotions right
now have my favor. You know actors. It still
happens to the social network. That's when Jonah play is the new guy
he's
white and brown I'm up and I read that he's won sixteen and here
you go back for number one sixteen something and I want to see the black They didn't let me play play.
As he sounds scary.
Allan yang. Welcome to FRESH AIR So one of the one of
the plot points and one of the
episodes is that if you're an actor if you're an Indian American actor.
There's only one Indian American per T.V. show. There can't be two.
So you're always up against a friend of yours for the same roles
and it's really awkward if that happens to you in real life.
That same exact situation hasn't happened to me but I do
know some Indian American actors who have relayed stories
of auditioning for shows and basically saying well they already got
their Indian guy. They already filled their quota. So they're not going to cast me
as well and then me and Alan the writers started talking about
this about whether they would ever cast to like what would happen if two guys
were really good like if they're doing a show with three people like what would
they do if two of the best guys were both union guys would they cast them
both and that conversation where we never really figured out what the answer
is became the germ of the idea for the episode.
And the thing about that your character refuses to do an Indian accent
and I mean this is true even if it's the role of a cab driver who's
an immigrant from India. So why would
you like declined to do an Indian accent. Even if you're doing a character who is
actually recently arrived in America.
Well to be clear I don't think doing that accent is totally wrong I think that's a personal choice
that an actor has to make whether they want to do that for me personally. Any time I've
been asked to do that I feel
like feels like it's making fun of people that have that X. and if I do it and
don't have that voice. It just doesn't feel right to me and it feels like you're doing it so
why people can laugh at Indian people. It feels kind of mean to me in some ways and it depends on the script
or something. It was like an intense
drama about an Indian cab driver and
it's this deep passionate story and you have to do an accent OK then it's like All
right well I maybe would do it for that if it's something like that but if it's the guy sitting in
a cab and it's me saying something in X. and making a joke about curry spilling on my
pants. I don't see the merits and that one.
Yeah a lot of it has to do with John or a
because obviously there are exceptions but something
about accents foreign accent specifically in comedy is a little tricky
and a lot of has to do with history because the history of Indian Asian people.
In movies and T.V. is really fraught with difficulty and a lot of
these characters you see Mickey Rooney in Breakfast at Tiffany's and
almost to a man the Asian and Indian characters throughout film history have
been before moons played for laughs So it's difficult and there are obviously great exceptions
of people doing accents and doing a great job but it's a tough personal choice.
So I want to play another clip from the episode of master of none called. Indians on T.V.
and in this scene is easier character Dev's in a restaurant with friends talking about
racism and comparing the kind of solidarity that African-Americans have when it comes to
racism and
how people get that but that it's different if
you're Indian American So you're specifically here talking to your friend Denise who's
African-American and a lesbian.
Want to meet people get that fired up about race. Asian or Indian like you only really rich start
a brouhaha. If you think I'm bad about black people or gay people. I mean apology and I
said I don't want. Iranian
people don't really care. This go back to you know this can you have a problem do you know what the
way the policy in the back making started come true but she did have
to apologize right like she had to go meet with Al Sharpton. I mean that's kind of the punishment right yet to
find Al Sharpton and go after you with him or
whatever so we don't have a person like that like who are supposed to meet with Deepak Chopra.
So this gets to a larger question and your episode also raises is when you
call somebody out for
racism and. When you're going too far when do you call them out and what might
the consequences be if you do is that an issue that you both thought about a lot.
I think so that's a lot of what the episode is about and one thing we try to do with the
show in general I feel like now there is this click bait culture on the Internet
where everyone
is quick to just say something like all that person's racist or
nothing's racist and things about race will really spread
around and Al and I in the show wanted to create a
dialogue where it was less about this kind
of condemning people quickly and more about having a dialogue and a
conversation and hearing other perspectives and have all these different characters.
Denise black woman. Brian Asian guy. Dev Indian
guy talking about these issues and how they feel about it and seeing it progress
throughout the episode or making the show sound really funny.
It is a comedy it's really very funny I promise this is just the
best it is really funny and one of things I really like about the series
is I really like your character he's he's a decent person I mean he's
funny he's sometimes a little
selfish but he's decent he tries often to do the right thing he
does have empathy. It's not us. It's not. I mean there's a snarky character
but there's it's not a snarky show. It's not a show that's just
always bathing in like cynicism and. And that's and snark.
And yet it's funny that the kind of sensibility you were shooting
for yeah I think so we were trying to make that character very empathetic.
We also wanted to depict this character that's not just a man child per se which is a
character you see a lot in these kind of comedies in the film as well just. The guy's
not separate getting knocked up like he has his life together to a certain
point and he's pretty mature for the most part and to us we want to explore what happens to
a guy that does have his life together and is a little bit mature who's still struggling with
his life decisions and already has some basic stuff together.
So there's a great episode about two of the main characters in the series is he's
your
character dev and then another character named Brian
who's Asian American They both they both don't know a lot
about their parents their parents are both immigrants who came to the United States.
Brian's parents are from
Taiwan Dev's parents are from
India and neither of them really know much about
their parents' back story but they often don't have time for their parents you know
like Deb's father wants to show him how to do something on his i Pad with the
calendar and dad just doesn't have time for that and Brian's father
wants him to show him something and Brian wants to get to the movie early enough so you can see the
trivia
contest
really important so they decided you know what. Let's let's we never get a chance to
say thank you to our parents for all the
sacrifices they've made you know to you know come to America and bring us up
in you know in the United States so we could have good lives so they decided to
take their parents out to dinner they go to an
Asian restaurant
and this is where the stories start coming out that. Never heard before about
their parents' lives are each of you first generation.
Yes. I think it's very accurate in the show are our parents are both immigrants.
Yeah those countries. Those are our real parents stories for the most part there are slight changes we
made but in the beginning of the episode there's a flashback of both of the
dads showing their journey coming from India or Taiwan to America
and all the you know old struggles they went through and it's based on a real
dad that was right that episode the germ of that episode actually started when
I remember I was sitting in a Z's hotel room. And we were trying to work on the show and I told
him the story about my dad which is real which is that he grew up
in five hundred square foot hut in Taiwan with a single
mother and two brothers and he didn't have enough food to the point where he
had to kill his pet chicken when he was eight years old or something to eat it for dinner
and I was talking to these and said And now his son gets to sit in a hotel room with the
famous comedian and work on a T.V. show when it was just so staggering
and Aziz
had similar stories about the sacrifices his family had made and it's just something you kind
of take for granted sometimes the children of immigrants and it's very legitimate all
the emotions in that episode are very real because I felt that guilt before I think of these as
to so. You know for a lot of people they can visit their parents
like old neighborhood which might be in the same city or in another state
but like Alan you're never going to be able to go to like the hut that your father grew up
in in Taiwan I'm sure that doesn't even exist anymore but you know it's just so that
that distance is so great it must
be really difficult for you to imagine what your father's life was
like that's absolutely true and it's funny you should say that the one time I
visited Taiwan I was seven years old and I actually did visit
that really and it. Yes. It's in a town a small village called tiger
tail. And my dad's mom stayed there for the rest of her life and
it was really interesting
because when my dad was born he was the youngest of three sons and
his father passed away when he was one year old and the people in the village told his
mom to give him away because
he was just it was just too much he was a single mom with three kids and his
mom worked in a factory making the burlap sacks for rice.
So she wasn't exactly rolling in
money but she decided to keep my dad and my dad ended up being a really
smart hardworking kid and he would go help with a factory and it's all sort of test
taking based in Taiwan so he took a standardized test in high school and did really well and
he was able to go to a straight medical school program. So
he ended up being really successful he came to America moved to New York then moved to
California and even after all
that he thought about bringing his mother over to
America but it was just too too drastic a change so she stayed in Taiwan
and it is a different. It is a there is a psychic goal set exists
between myself and my grandparents because they don't really speak English and I don't speak
Chinese and that's my own personal shame feels I did not learn ever
but yeah I only saw my my paternal grandma a few times in
my life and that's really that's really crazy I think yeah you know all these white people visit their grandparents all
the time and and I think there's a bit in the show about these talking to his grandparents
it's the same thing with mine. If I'm talking the phone to my grandma. She doesn't speak English and I don't speak
Chinese so I'm not sure what we're supposed to say is these what did you learn
about your parents from trying to get their stories out so you could put them in your series.
I basically learned the stories that ended up being in that second episode.
My mom told
me it's like a it's described in the episode where she says that she got
here the first day but in my mom's case it was South Carolina and in the show that character is.
New York but my mom she came to South Carolina.
My dad picked up from the airport to group home and then my dad had to go to the hospital and
work and so she sitting in this apartment in South Carolina. She doesn't know anyone she's all alone.
She's she had an arranged marriage so she'd known my dad for about a
week which is true it's in the absolute Well she met my dad a week later they got
married and then she's in
America and she's just there in this apartment asked her like what did you.
What did you do that first day like Did you watch D.V.D.'s like read a book and and it's I put it in
the absolute because it hit you so hard you said no I just sat on the couch and
cried and you hear that and you're like
wow these people really did something pretty incredible to
get here and give me this spectacular life that I've been able to have and I've never really thought
about it I never thought about them coming to South Carolina and trying to build a life in
the strange place where they didn't know anybody and dealing
with racism and and
like much harder racism than like well I got to
do an accent in the audition like real stuff where people are just people they're pretty
good you know.
So it was. It was it was a great conversation to have and
I
think a lot of immigrant kids probably don't have that conversation with their parents because it is kind
of
odd even if you're not immigrant to be like Mom Dad tell me your story like let's let's talk
about that it just feels kind of odd to bring that up and I think it's one of those things where kids like I'll
ask them at some point and then I bet a lot of times they don't end up doing it and they
never get to learn these
stories. As these your parents play your parents
in the series and why did you cast your
parents strikes me it's working out great in terms of my perspective is if you were
it strikes me. It could have the potential to be very awkward.
Well Alan and I had those characters.
My parents. And we knew the character of my dad was going to pop up in a few episodes and he
was based
on my real dad the way we wrote the character and my real dad
is very funny and
silly and for me it was very important that we got these characters right because a
lot of times we see immigrant parents on television or film. They're
portrayed in this unbelievably broad fashion and they're just vehicles
for very
hacky ethnic jokes that are not real. So we wanted these characters to feel
three dimensional and
real and we auditioned a few people for these parts of my parents and when
they read they just didn't feel like my parents they didn't feel it felt
like people doing impressions of Indian people and they just didn't
have the
timing and humor that my real parents had I think my mom's funny too.
And they just didn't feel right. And those parts are really important.
So they they both agreed to do it and it really was
a really strange is usually when people have their real parents do things. It's a pretty
quick cameo type situation or like one scene there. They were in it a lot and you know
they it wasn't like they came into town for a couple of days they were here for like two weeks working on the
show and dad took off work from being a
gastroenterologist to do an arc on my show. It's a pretty crazy thing you did and I really
have to thank them tremendously because I think their work is great and it's crazy
to read reviews where it's like shout at them. Sorry comes in and steals
the scene which.
Which is a of course not going to go to my dad at all.
So as these your parents had an arranged marriage they knew each other week before they got
married
and you do a lot of comedy about dating and romance you have a book
that you co-wrote with a sociologist called Modern Romance.
Must be really hard. When in your mind you compare your parents.
With your idea of what a relationship should be.
Yes I think it's such a
vast difference in the way that whole process is for
me today than it was for my parents back then and we talk
about that in them so whenever I'm having a conversation my dad I think it's an episode
ten and I'm asking him like how many women do to me before he decided to marry
my mom that's the real story he told me
that he met two people my mom was a second person
and the first lady thought she was a little bit too to hold my mom.
And I was like well how and you talked about it before you decided to get married he said like thirty minutes and
then he was he was good and then you look at me now
and if we have like a lunch menu we will
spend thirty minutes trying to figure out what the best is yet before we pull the trigger on an order.
And then once I get them both and yeah.
One one of the writers on Parks and Rec Harris widows died at the age of
thirty and. These you wrote a really nice piece
about
him after he died and I'm just I
guess I'm wondering what it's like for both of
you. To have a contemporary colleague who was a
contemporary who died. I think when someone your own age dies.
It's just a fundamentally different experience than when somebody older
especially considerably older than you
dies. Yeah that was one of the
most difficult days I think of both of our lives. Hare's
was someone who
was. Someone we saw every day you know I
had what he was writing on the show when he the time he worked on Match of non And. He
was working on your show. Absolutely it was after it was after parks and
when Alan and I were coming up on the show one of the first things we said is we've got to
get Wiggles to be on our staff to. With us if we can get little it will be so huge because he was
really he's really was the strongest writer that we could think of
to get on board with us and we got him to work on the show with us which is so
flattering because he's pretty is pretty picky about what he would do and he would just kind of anything.
And yeah he was working with us every day he was in the writers' room with us and
he wasn't there this one day.
He
was writing with this. Man it's really hard to talk about this but we're working on the
show and we got that phone call and I just screamed I couldn't believe it and I
was separate from me now and we're working separately from the other writers and I
told our what happened and we were just in shock and we just.
We just walked around the neighborhood for a while I was trying to walk. Yeah we're just trying to process this and
then. Oh God it was a nightmare and then we had to go in
and it was such a weird thing where those awful websites
like we're just like posting about this before people he
knew could even find out
and it was one of these things are like we've got to tell them or else they're going to see it on like T M
Z or something like that and so I went in and told
everyone and it was it was an unbelievably
difficult horrible experience and
it was. It was it was awful.
I'm glad that we got to spend so much time with him before he passed because we were seeing him every day
and I'm happy that I got to spend as much time with him as
I did before he left and.
You know you see there's moments in the show that are
such heris moments that. I'm so glad are in there
and it's such it's so sad that he's not able to see what we
ended up doing with some of the great stuff he did.
But it's yeah it's like Alan and I would scream when we were working on the
show we would screen the episodes. We'd have like a long added other episode in the
do screenings and we would screen stuff and Harris's stuff would get such huge laughs and we're just
like look at each other we're like laughing and also sad at the same time it's such a weird
feeling like people would be at the screening a friend would just text like oh my God like that line
is great like who wrote that and I feel like I was
Harry and he was he was just a crazy comedy machine
and just to give an example of his personality he himself would
say he was the fifth or sixth funniest person in the world and we would often ask him who
was above him at that point in time and he would say OK well Galifianakis
Louis and right now I think McBride and Larry David are a little funnier than I am but I'm probably
five or six. Yes Like it really was.
You know there are a lot of funny people those writers rooms but what he was
just just so naturally talented and it was infuriating So to ask this guy would stroll
in and he was always the most confident dude and just be the
funniest as he's I'm sorry. And Allan yang. Thank you and congratulations
on your new series. Thanks very much Terry thanks for having us. Thank
you as he's Ansari and Allen Yang co-created the Netflix series
master of none which Ansari also stars in our interview was recorded in November.
If you're looking for things to listen to over the holiday weekend. Check out our podcast
where you'll find some of our favorite interviews of the year which we featured this week with Larry
Wilmore Collinge Austin Michael Che townhouse he coats. Gloria Steinem and
Jeffrey Tambor.
All of us are fresh air wish you a Happy and Healthy New
Year and if this is a difficult time for you because of illness or other problems in
life we hope things will be better for you in two thousand and sixteen. We'll
close with a recording of the new year standard. By B.B. King one of the great
artists we lost this year.
Fresh Air's executive producer is Danny Miller our interviews and reviews are produced in
edited by
Amy Salat C.S. Myers. And we're able to not oh Sam Briger Lauren Krenzel John she
and Heidi simón and to reason that with our technical director an engineer as Reggie
Benson Dorothy Ferebee is our diminished rate of assistance our associate producer for online
media is Molly C.V.S. for Roberta her rock directs the show. I'm Terry Gross.
Thank.